Narrator: WHEN YOU'RE HUNGRY,
YOU NEVER
QUITE HAVE THE RIGHT COINS
FOR THE SNACK YOU WANT.
HOW DOES THE MACHINE KNOW
TO SEND BACK ANYTHING FAKE
AND KEEP TRACK
OF HOW MUCH YOU'VE PAID?
THE MACHINE DECIPHERS
COINS WITH PINPOINT ACCURACY.
LIGHT SENSORS MEASURE THE SIZE,
AND ELECTROMAGNETS
DETECT THE METAL TYPE,
IDENTIFYING THE COINS
IN SPLIT SECONDS
AND SORTING THEM INTO COLUMNS,
DIVERTING FAKES
TO THE REJECT CHUTE.
WHEN CHANGE IS DUE,
THE COLUMNS CAREFULLY
RELEASE ONE COIN AT A TIME...
...TUMBLING INTO THE CHUTE.
THESE 85 PARTS WORK TOGETHER
TO COUNT 15,000 COINS A YEAR
AND RELEASE YOUR SNACK
AT THE TOUCH OF A BUTTON.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE HUNGRY,
THERE'S NOTHING MORE FRUSTRATING
THAN YOUR SNACK GETTING STUCK.
HOW DO TODAY'S GENERATION
OF VENDING MACHINES
MAKE SURE
YOU GET YOUR TREAT EVERY TIME?
HIDDEN BEHIND THE KEYS,
A COMPUTER ORDERS
1 OF 32 MATCHBOX-SIZED MOTORS...
...TO TURN THE SPIRAL
360 DEGREES.
AS THE SNACK FALLS,
IT BREAKS A LINE
OF 10 INFRARED BEAMS.
IF NOTHING CROSSES THE BEAMS,
THE COMPUTER
MAKES THE COILS TURN AGAIN.
WITH THIS INGENIOUS TECHNOLOGY,
YOU'LL ALWAYS GET YOUR SNACK
AND NEVER LEAVE HUNGRY.